good morning cake it's tuesday so last
week the washington post published a
brilliantly reported gut-wrenching story
about a 17-year-old girl susan
navigating the complexities of an
unexpected high-risk pregnancy in sierra
leone susan's mother died in childbirth
and the story helps us understand the
incredibly difficult choices people must
make in a country where one in 20 women
will die from being pregnant i thought
this story was really important so i
retweeted it and the response to my
tweet that received the most engagement
and therefore that twitter showed the
most people was how did she become
unexpectedly pregnant did she have sex
without protection where did the
surprise come from now as it happens
that question is answered in the article
which i encourage everyone to read but i
want to focus on the response because at
first blush it seems merely offensive
like if you read the sentence an
unexpectedly pregnant 17 year old girl
whose mother died giving birth to her
must navigate an impoverished health
care system to try to survive her
extremely high risk pregnancy it rather
misses the point to focus on the word
unexpectedly but i think there is
something near universal driving that
response which is that we all look for
reasons not to care and especially
reasons not to intervene like these days
a new horror pops up in our feeds every
280 characters or every 10 tick tock
seconds and we cannot possibly respond
to all of these crises so we look for
reasons not to they did that to
themselves they shouldn't have gotten
addicted to drugs there are bad guys on
both sides there's nothing i can do
anyway those idiots deserve it the
government's corrupt she should have
expected to get pregnant as we've
discussed recently hank nobody can care
about everything all of the time there
are limits to empathy and indeed there
must be like 155 000 people are going to
die today and if i grieved each of those
losses the way i would grieve the death
of a loved one i wouldn't be able to
function but if our way out of having
limited empathy is to deny or minimize
the suffering of others we are doing
them and ourselves a great disservice
the truth is there will always be a
reason not to care governments are
corrupt people do make bad choices and
if a person or a cause has to pass some
imagined purity test in order to receive
our compassion and attention we won't be
able to extend our compassion to anyone
including ourselves susan's pregnancy
was unexpected she'd been told she
couldn't get pregnant but more to the
point health disparities are not driven
by personal choices or values they are
driven by inequity and injustice we know
that it's about systems and equitable
access in part because we know that
through system strengthening it is
possible to radically reduce maternal
mortality like because sierra leone's
healthcare system is getting stronger in
part due to investments made by our
community maternal mortality there has
declined by more than 10 percent just in
the last five years these improvements
are happening because of commitments
from the government because of the
incredibly hard work of sierra leonean
healthcare workers and support staff and
also because people are choosing to care
people in our community and elsewhere
are choosing to focus their attention
and their resources to help bring about
a world where no one dies for want of a
blood transfusion or an emergency
c-section this is not about whether
someone should have expected a pregnancy
this is about whether someone should be
able to expect to survive pregnancy p.s
if you want to donate to our project to
radically reduce maternal mortality in
sierra leone the link is pih.org
hank and john you can learn more in the
doobly-doo where you can also read the
washington post article and whether you
can donate or not thank you for caring
hank i'll see you on friday